[Applaus]
die
us-staffel ein flugzeugträger der us
navy
der in krisengebieten eingesetzt wird
wenn ein flugzeugträger auftaucht ist
die lage meist angespannt
ort über 70 leistungsstarke flugzeuge
und eine hochspezialisierte besatzung
[Musik]
wir erreichen krisengebiet der in
kürzester zeit
diese mission wird eine herausforderung
das ziel der nahe osten
der gefährlichsten einsatzgebiete die es
gibt
es geht um
leben oder tod
[Musik]
april 2017
die uss george bush ist unterwegs im
persischen golf
ihre besatzung rüstet die flugzeuge an
bord für einen kampfeinsatz aus
[Musik]
seit wochen fliegen sie von hier
einsätze gegen den sogenannten
islamischen staates die crew arbeitet
hochkonzentriert trotz arbeitszeiten von
bis zu 14 stunden in sengender hitze
[Musik]
zwei ebenen unter dem flugdeck bereiten
sich lieutenant commander lockt farrell
und drei weitere piloten auf ihren flug
in den iranischen luftraum vor
sie unterstützen die verbündeten am
boden dabei könnten sie auch in gefechte
mit gegnerischen flugzeugen verwickelt
werden
es ist wesentlich härter als die anderen
vier bei denen ich bisher dabei war
ich war noch nie an richtigen
kampfhandlungen beteiligt so geht es den
meisten von uns
es ist nicht leicht jeden tag
rauszufliegen doch die piloten haben
eine aufgabe zu erfüllen
wir unterstützen die operationen herren
resound die amerikanischen boden trocken
und die unsere verbündeten müssen aus
der luft unterstützt werden das tun wir
so gut wie keine mehr
ihre maschinen sind f a 18 super hornet
sie übernehmen einen großteil der
luftangriffe
[Musik]
sie werden vom träger katapultiert
und fliegen richtung ihrer
links jetzt wird es ernst
jeder ist sehr konzentriert
der ausgang ist ungewiss
doch die uss busch und ihre piloten
haben sich lange auf diese mission
vorbereitet
[Musik]
rückblende ein monat zuvor der
flugzeugträger bewegt sich langsam an
der griechischen küste entlang
er ist 23 stockwerke hoch mehr als drei
fußballfelder lang und bis zu 97 1000
tonnen schwer die uss bush hat nur eine
funktion sie ist start und landebahn für
kampfflugzeuge
allein das flugdeck ist 1,8 hektar groß
wir sind ein schwimmender flughafen so
bleibt die us navy unabhängig
wir brauchen keine genehmigung für die
errichtung eines luftwaffenstützpunktes
oder überflugrechte und wir erreichen
krisengebiete in kürzester zeit
die wichtigste waffe der uss busch ist
ihr träger geschwader
aus über 70 hoch spezialisierten
flugzeugen
[Musik]
das career erinnert
ich glaube nicht dass es in den usa oder
in irgendeinem anderen land etwas gibt
das strategisch wertvoller ist als ein
träger gespeichert
wenn eine internationale krise ausbricht
fragt der präsident als erstes wo ist
unser flugzeug kalkar
für ihren aktuellen einsatz ist die uss
busch von ihrem heimathafen in norfolk
virginia über den atlantik bis ins
mittelmeer gereist
hier wird drei wochen trainiert bevor es
weitergeht sie ist der persische golf
dort werden wir im rahmen der operation
flug angriffe gegen stellungen des
islamischen staates
einige städte sind noch in der hand des
e s
wir werden einen plan entwickeln wie wir
den bodentruppen in diesen gebieten
helfen können
das problem die piloten waren seit drei
jahren nicht mehr an kampfhandlungen
beteiligt
ich wünschte fliegen wäre so einfach wie
radfahren ist es aber nicht
wenn man es eine weile nicht gemacht hat
also fahren wir als erstes raus und
machen die piloten wieder fit damit die
einsätze vom flugzeug aus fliegen
von einem flugzeugträger zu stärken und
sicher auf ihr zu landen ist eine kunst
das schafft nur ein speziell
ausgebildeter pilot
an land für start und landung bis zu
zweieinhalb kilometer zur verfügung auf
einem flugzeugträger sind es höchstens
120 m
die marine luftfahrt des gnadenlos wenn
man nicht hundertprozentig konzentriert
und trainiert ist
man es da nicht lassen
um auf so kurzer strecke zu starten
braucht das flugzeug extraschub
die lösung ein katapult
der sogenannte ketchup bringt eine 25
tonnen schwere maschine in nur zwei
sekunden von null auf 240 km pro stunde
[Musik]
als würde man aus einer kanone
geschossen das macht wach und gibt einen
ordentlichen schub
der stern ist schon eine herausforderung
aber die landung hat es so richtig in
sich
das schwierigste ist die landung der
rückflug zum chef ist ziemlich lang
man ist gerade dehydriert und hat die
ganze zeit in einem schleudersitz
gesessen das ist nicht gerade
ist körperlich total geschafft muss sich
aber trotzdem darauf konzentrieren sich
auf dem schiff
was es noch schwieriger macht das
flugdeck bewegt sich mit den wellen auf
und ab
in den sekunden vor der landung müssen
die piloten zahlreiche kleine
anpassungen vornehmen um das flugzeug
perfekt auf das deckt auszurichten
hochkonzentriert sind hat der einsatz
über sieben stunden gedauert und ist
super gelaufen wenn man dann zurückkommt
und sich einen fehler leistet ist das
kein happy end
eine f a 18 kommt mit über 240 kilometer
pro stunde auf dem flugdeck auf
für das abbremsen muss der pilot eines
von mehreren fang seilen mit seinem fang
haken erwischen
es gibt drei seile
[Musik]
man muss eins davon mit dem haken
zugreifen bekommen um nicht über den
landesbereich hinauszuschießen
[Musik]
auf dem weg richtung persischer golf
trainiert dass er im geschwader was das
zeug hält sie müssen alle abläufe und
bewegungen verinnerlichen
denn im gefecht heißt es anderen nicht
denken
er hat sich müssen jedes mal versuchen
perfekt zu sein
es gibt keinen raum für fehler
in nur wenigen tagen müssen sie ihre
fähigkeiten im ernstfall unter beweis
stellen
die uss busch nähert sich ihrem
zielgebiet die vorbereitungen auf den
einsatz laufen auf hochtouren
im irak kämpfen die vereinigten staaten
an der seite einheimischer truppen gegen
den sogenannten islamischen staates sie
sind auf die unterstützung der uss bus
angewiesen
sobald diese den persischen golf
erreicht muss die fliegerstaffel mit den
luftangriffen beginnen
doch bereits auf dem weg dorthin könnte
es brenzlig werden im suezkanal
der suez kanal ist eine wichtige
abkürzung vom mittelmeer zum roten meer
auf der einen seite liegt das ägyptische
festland auf der anderen die sinai
halbinsel
diese 61.000 quadratkilometer große
wüstenlandschaft gilt als ägyptens
wilder westen
hier dürfen wir keine flut operation
hindurch schießen also können die f a 18
nichts kennt wir müssen uns auf den
schutz der gibt er verlassen
der kanal bringt der ägyptischen
regierung jedes jahr fünf milliarden
dollar ein sie hat also ein großes
interesse daran dass er sicher befahren
werden kann
die uss busch muss auf ihrem weg durch
das fast 200 kilometer langen nadelöhr
darauf vertrauen dass das ägyptische
militär alles zu ihrem schutz tut
sollte jemand die ägyptische
verteidigung über winden haben die
hubschrauber der uss busch die
genehmigung einzugreifen
sie können uns beschützen was ein land
eine seiner kampfflugzeuge los schickt
uns anzugreifen
oder ein terrorist mit einem kleinen
flugzeug schaden anrichten
der flugzeugträger hat zwei varianten
des siegs kitty hawk an bord die im h60
sierras werden vom hubschrauber
geschwader neuen den tridays geflogen
die immer 60 romeos von den spartans
beide seahawks sind bis an die zähne
bewaffnet
nach vorne gerichtet das m 240 ein
manuell bedient das maschinengewehr mit
kaliber 7,62 ist es
hinter ist in der tür 1 321 kaliber 50
angebracht eine sehr leistungsstarke
waffe auf dem meer haben wir damit mehr
reichweite eigentlich über ein
zwei tage vor der durchfahrt machen die
hubschrauber einen ausflug über das
mittelmeer sie wollen ihre waffen an
einem kleinen unbemannten blut testen
wir bereiten uns auf den persischen golf
dort werden wir es wahrscheinlich mit
ähnlichem zu tun bekommen
kleine schnellboote stellen im kanal die
größte gefahr dar
die hubschrauberpiloten können heute
üben wie sie damit umgehen
wir dürfen es beschießen und zerstört so
sehen wir wie es ist wenn unsere kugeln
das ziel treffen also was wir zielen
müssen um den größten schaden
anzurichten
mit dem training wollen wir sozusagen
das messer schärfen bevor wir ins
kampfgebiet kaum
nachdem die hubschrauber gelandet sind
bereitet die crew an bord der uss bush
eine weitere schießübung vor die waffe
ein nahbereichs verteidigungssystem kurz
service genannt
diese 20 mm vulkan maschinen kann ohne
steckt in einem beweglichen fast fünf
meter hohen gehäuse
im oberen teil befinden sich zwei
antennen
sie wollten den angreifer und richten
die waffe aus
die wolken feuert 4000 zu es in der
minute jede kugel ist fast doppelt so
groß wie die normale maschinengewehre
sie kann sogar noch ein ziel in acht
kilometern entfernung treffen
[Musik]
einen tag bevor die uss bush den suez
kanal erreicht führt die crew mit dem
system noch einen finalen check durch
während der durchquerung ist es die
einzige verteidigungs möglichkeit des
schiffes
wir wissen dass wir uns in ein mögliches
gefahrengebiet begeben
sobald wir im kanal sind wir in
alarmbereitschaft und achten auf alles
um uns herum
wenn uns jemand angreift werden wir es
ihm richtig schwer machen wir können in
kurzer zeit so einiges auffahren
[Musik]
egal was kommt
die uss busch ist gut gerüstet
aber reicht das im ernstfall aus
es gibt immer etwas an das man nicht
gedacht hat oder eine situation die man
nicht vorhersehen konnten
[Musik]
hier sag immer unterschätzt
die passage durch den suez kanal steht
nun kurz bevor
[Musik]
ein letztes mal gehen die navigations
offiziere die einzelnen schritte durch
die
[Musik]
planung hat monate gedauert weil wir das
schiff in keiner weise in gefahr bringen
wollen
ok
wir haben uns den kurs anderer
flugzeugträger angesehen die vor uns
durchgefahren sind damit den sicheren
gewässern bleiben
die uss busch ist gut 40 meter breit sie
nimmt mehr als die hälfte des kanals ein
terroristen könnten mit einem boot
leicht den weg blockieren
wir schulen die teams auf der brücke
damit sie mit jeder situation umgehen
können die denken
wir entwickeln notfallpläne die auf
mögliche szenarien basieren
das reicht von einer normalen gefährdung
bis zu größtmöglicher
sind also aufs schlimmste vorbereitet
[Musik]
am frühen morgen fährt das schiff in den
kanal 1
das ägyptische militär an land behält
alles im blick
die ägyptische armee für vor uns her es
wird in suez kanal durchquert
und ihre luftwaffe hatte hubschrauber
auf deck ist die anspannung greifbar
unter deck ist es ein tag wie jeder
andere
es muss gekocht werden
gewaschen
und geschraubt
[Musik]
die crew die für die flugzeuge
verantwortlich ist genießt ihren freien
tag eine seltenheit
was machen wir an so einem tag wir sehen
uns die ist ziemlich eindrucksvoll
ist mal was anderes rechts und links
land zu sehen
auf see für die uss busch bis zu 55
kilometer in der stunde auf dem kanal
dürfen es nicht mehr als 310 sein weil
ihr kühlwasser sonst das ufer
beschädigen könnte
auf halber strecke passiert der
flugzeugträger die suez kanal brücke
sie verbindet ägypten mit der sinai
halbinsel
und war aus sicherheitsgründen fast zwei
jahre lang gesperrt
der ausblick ist imposant
neben den 154 meter hohen pylonen wirkt
der massige flugzeugträger fast klein
[Musik]
einige kollegen an bord können den
anblick bewundern
doch die brücken besatzung bleibt in hab
acht stellung
wir konnten uns entspannt zurücklehnen
weil alles reibungslos abläuft aber
konzentriert selbst wenn der kanal schon
weit hinter uns liegt
nach 14 stunden
haben sie es geschafft
doch das war nur die halbe miete
auf dem weg zum persischen golf muss die
uss bush noch durch die gefährliche
meerenge bei palm an dub und die straße
von hormus
entlang der krisengeschüttelten länder
jemen somalia und iran
die uss busch ist hier nicht unbedingt
gern gesehen
eine ebene unter dem flugdeck alten
admiral kenner schweizer und seine
nachrichten offiziere im taktischen
kommunikationszentrum augen und ohren
offen
es ist nervenzentrum und gehirn des
schiffs
auf zwölf riesigen monitoren treffen
unentwegt streng geheime daten über ein
gebiet ein das fast so groß ist wie die
usa
auf ihrer fahrt durch die meerengen
bleiben brezel und sein team in
ständiger alarmbereitschaft
gerade durch fahren wir die straße von
hormus vielleicht kommen wir an die
kritische stelle weil wir dort sowohl
dem iran als auch dem oman am nächsten
sind wir müssen sicherstellen dass der
truppe nicht passiert
hier gab es bereits einen zwischenfall
[Musik]
vor drei monaten näherte sich ein schiff
der iranischen revolutionsgarden einem
zerstörer die us navy das beunruhigt
reutzel und sein team
jeder im raum ist hochkonzentriert
während der nächsten sechs stunden
müssen sie alles im auge behalten was
sich in der region bewegt wir sind für
die sicherheit der truppe verantwortlich
wenn eine gefahr auftaucht müssen wir
uns verteidigen
endlich erreicht die uss bush den
persischen golf und befindet sich damit
in internationalen gewässern
[Applaus]
sie kommt gerade rechtzeitig
die irakischen truppen sind in einen
heftigen kampf um mossul verwickelt
mossul die zweitgrößte stadt im land
befindet sich seit jahren in der hand
des so genannten e s
es wäre ein großer erfolg für die
irakische armee wenn sie die stadt
zurückerobern könnte und für die
us-luftstreitkräfte die sie unterstützen
noch hat der irs die kontrolle aber er
wird immer weiter eingekesselt wir
fliegen luftangriffe um die bodentruppen
zu unterstützen
doch bevor die uss busch einen einsatz
starten kann muss sie noch treibstoff
für die flugzeuge besorgen
atombetriebenen ist haben wir keinen
treibstoff
die jets benötigen welche
während des einsatzes
das nennt sich see versorgung der
flugzeugträger läuft das
versorgungsschiff an und hält parallel
kurs
das ist leichter gesagt als getan
er muss genau die gleiche
geschwindigkeit haben wie der versorger
die uss busch schießt nach drüben eine
leine an der eintrag über geholt wird
das navigationssystem auf der brücke
beobachtet den vorgang aufmerksam
der kleinste fehler beim steuern könnte
zur kollision führen
im moment liegen etwa 50 meter zwischen
uns das ist ideal also versuchen wir das
zu halten
48 und 54 meter gehen da auch nicht
so haben wir genug spiel aus und können
die spannung im rat halten
nachdem der draht gespannt ist werden an
ihm die tank schläuche entlang geführt
die zapf ventile klinken ein und der
treibstoff schießt in den tank die
beiden schiffe hängen vier stunden auf
diese weise aneinander
wir sind an vier stellen miteinander
verbunden heute tanken wir über
viereinhalb millionen liter
die betankung ist abgeschlossen und das
schiff ist bereit für seine eigentliche
mission
auf dem flugdeck führen techniker letzte
wartungsarbeiten an den maschinen durch
unter deck treffen sich jugend commander
look farrell und die anderen fa 18
piloten zur lagebesprechung
ab morgen wird es ernst die flugzeuge
beginnen mit ihren luftangriffen
bush befindet sich jetzt rund 800
kilometer vor der iranischen küste
drei ebenen unter dem flugdeck erhalten
4 f a 18 super hornet piloten der black
lions staffel instruktionen für ihren
einsatz
in nicht mal zwei stunden fliegen sie
richtung irak
lieutenant commander s liebherr führt
das briefing durch alle vier piloten
müssen auf demselben stand sein
wir besprechen wie wir in das land
vordringen und wie der kampf einsatz
abläuft es ist wichtig dass wir alles
klären bevor wir im flugzeug setzen wenn
etwas unvorhergesehenes passiert können
wir besser damit umgehen
herr zach und verfliegen einer der f a
die lutens patrick lag uns dies es
folgen ihnen in der zweiten
ihr auftrag die infrastruktur der
terrorgruppe zu zerstören das heutige
ziel eine zementfabrik die zur
finanzierung des krieges beiträgt
die terroristen immer stärker zu werden
man versorgt immer durch gegnerische
infrastruktur zu verstehen finanzen
nahrungsmittel wasser
lager waffenfabriken das wurde bisher
bei jedem pixel gemacht
während die lagebesprechung noch in
vollem gange ist bestückt die crew an
deck die f a 18 mit den notwendigen
waffen
wir haben eine auswahl an sorten in
verschiedenen größen industries gibt es
auch an
schätzt die kleineren setzen wir bei
vielen ein die von dingen umgeben sind
wir nicht beschädigen wollen
der wüste wo es sonst nichts geht
verwenden wir die größeren
um eine zementfabrik zu zerstören
braucht man 2 900 kilogramm bomben jede
verursacht einen krater von 15 metern
durchmesser
wir setzen alles daran die bomben
positionen zur richtigen zeit abzulesen
auch wenn sich niemand in der gegend
aufhält der verletzt werden könnte
wollen wir die waffen die präzise
abwerfen
der ablauf vor einem einsatz ist immer
derselbe
etwa eine stunde und zehn minuten vor
dem start liegen wir die volle
ausrüstung an und stellen alles zusammen
was wir brauchen falls wert gott bewahre
abgeschlossen werden
danach gehen wir hoch zum flugtag machen
die vor flugkontrolle und dann geht's
los
farrell
überprüfen noch einmal die bomben
ich sehe immer noch mal nach ob wirklich
alles an bord ist
extrem wichtig
nur noch 20 minuten bis zum start
[Musik]
im kontrollierten chaos auf dem flugdeck
ist vertrauen zwar gut aber kontrolle
besser
nicht nur zu uns sondern auch für die
anderen
börseg und fero starten als erster
die super hornet rastet am katapult 1
die piloten warten auf den ruck beim
start
es ist immer wieder spannend
man weiß dass er kommt aber nicht genau
welcher sie
überrascht ein jedes mal
30 sekunden später sind clark und csu an
der reihe
[Musik]
in nur fünf minuten sind die beiden
flugzeuge über dem irak
ich bin noch nie gereicht das nahen
osten
eine riesige wüste mit einer stecken es
ist zwar kriegsgebieten kurz aber dort
leben menschen man fragt sich
die fa 18 kampfjets fliegen in
durchschnittlich 15 kilometern höhe
lange zeit waren sie dort vor den waffen
des sogenannten islamischen staates
sicher
doch seit sechs monaten ist es damit
vorbei
gs kämpfer erbeuteten ein
flugabwehrraketen system es kann ziele
erreichen die noch zehn kilometer höher
fliegen als die super hornet
immer im hinterkopf was tun wir gegen
eine feindliche raketen die auf uns
gefeiert wird
man muss ständig aufmerksam sein
[Musik]
die beiden f a 18 nähern sich ihrem ziel
und die piloten geben die koordinaten
für den abwurf der bomben ein
[Musik]
plötzlich wird es wirklich ernst jeder
ist hochkonzentriert wenn es steht viel
auf dem spiel
die piloten machen einen letzten scan
überprüfen ihre koordinaten
und werfen die bomben ab
wenn eine 900 kilogramm schwere bombe
aus 15 kilometern höhe abgeworfen wird
schlägt sie nach nur 30 sekunden am
boden auf
[Applaus]
beide treffen das ziel punktgenau
sicher ist dass man alles richtig gesagt
hat wartet man noch die detonation bis
dahin scheint die zeit stillzustehen
weniger als eine minute später trifft
auch die zweite f a 18 genau ins
schwarze
die bomben abzuwerfen ist nur ein teil
der mission
jetzt folgt der schwierigste
er hat meine gedanken kreisen nur noch
darum sicher auf dem schiff zu lang
egal wie oft man s macht es wird nicht
leicht
plötzlich bemerkt farrell etwas
ungewöhnliches an seinen instrumenten
ihm wird klar dass diese landung noch
komplizierter werden wird als sonst
pelzig und faire überlegen was sie tun
sollen ein bremsdefekt könnte zu
weiteren komplikationen führen
was können sich auf andere systeme
auswirken am ende könnten
wir konnten nicht wirklich etwas machen
farrell gibt den piloten der anderen f a
18 über funk bescheid jetzt kann er nur
noch aufs beste offen er weiß nicht ob
die landung reibungslos klappt oder
nicht
an deck der uss busch bereitet sich die
crew auf die rückkehr der beiden super
hornets vor
farrow und per 60 minuten vor einer
landung mit ungewissem ausgang
[Musik]
es ist hoch entwickelt wenn sie das hat
meldet sie sich
die piloten haben keine zeit nach dem
grund zu suchen
sie funken den tower an und teilen ihnen
mit dass es ein problem geben könnte
[Musik]
ich sagte ihm dass wir nicht genau
wissen ob unsere bremsen beide london
normal funktionieren würden oder
optionen
der tür gibt die anweisung dass die
andere f a 18 zuerst landen soll
nachdem diese unten ist wird sie sofort
aus dem weg manövriert
jetzt beginnen fällen perfekt mit dem
landeanflug
aus fünf kilometern entfernung sieht das
flugdeck so klein aus wie eine
briefmarke
doch wenn man mit 240 kilometer pro
stunde darauf zu gast wird es schnell
ziemlich groß
besonders in so einem fall zahlt sich
das training aus was sich einfach nur
auf sein
[Musik]
die zweite f a 18 kommt zum stehen
normalerweise wird das flugzeug schnell
vom fang sei gelöst doch pelzig und
farrell wissen nicht wie ihre bremsen
reagieren also warten sie noch ab sie
riskieren sonst vom deck zu holen
wir haben die triebwerke noch laufen
lassen und wurden mit einer zugmaschine
weg ist
[Musik]
dass die sache nun stellen dazu und
kostet sich woanders auf der flucht
die flugzeugtechniker bringen den jet in
den hangar
sie müssen ihn für seinen nächsten
einsatz fit machen
im bereitschaftsraum erwartet die vier
piloten ein herzliche empfang
[Musik]
und sind dort relativ sicher
unsere fliegerstaffel ist groß genug
dass wir jetzt erst einmal drei oder
vier tage pause
[Musik]
da jetzt von vorne los
wir haben noch einige einsätze vor und
[Musik]
halbzeit an bord der uss busch seit drei
monaten ist die crew auf see ständig
einsatzbereit die komplexen abläufe auf
dem flugzeugträger sind zur routine
geworden
die us navy ist oft als erster vor ort
wir helfen auch nach naturkatastrophen
mit hubschraubern aus
unser flugzeugträger und die über 5000
männer und frauen helfen
wir haben über jahre die flexibilität
des flugzeugträgers und die schlagkraft
des erding unter beweis gestellt das
schiff ist ein wichtiger teil der jurist
[Musik]
ein anstrengender aber gute arbeitsplatz